bonjour merci à d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors cette
manifestation aujourd'hui devant seither
le message que votre parti souhaite
faire passer
le premier message c'est que le vaccin
ne peut pas être un business
on voit bien que l'exploitation par
quelques firmes de ce qui devrait être
selon nous être un bien commun de
l'humanité faire tomber les brevets
avoir des licences public de façon à
produire massivement pour lutter le plus
efficacement possible contre cette
pandémie
mondiale notre premier message en
manifestant devant le siège de freezer
c'est de cesser de dire
à la fois un finder est aussi au
gouvernement français et à l'union
européenne que le vaccin et que la lutte
contre une pandémie mondiale comme le
colis de 19 ne peut pas être dans la
main des trusts pharmaceutiques ce que
vous dites c'est ce qui bloque
aujourd'hui les la chaîne de production
finalement c'est ce brevet donc il faut
lever le bras c'est ce que vous dites
on voit bien que dans notre pays la
france qui malheureusement fait partie
des
du seul qui est le seul pays du conseil
de sécurité de la nation n'y a pas avoir
produit son vaccin
nous voyons bien que nous sommes
tributaires de la production
le vaccin par des firmes étrangères donc
nous demandons à la fois la mise à
contribution des chaînes de production
de sanofi et d'autres industries
pharmaceutique française et nous
demandons aussi la levée des brevets le
versement des différents vaccins en
licence publique pour que ça puisse être
produit à la hauteur de ce qui est
nécessaire pour lutter contre une
pandémie mondiale
car bien évidemment il ya le niveau de
la vaccination dans notre pays
en france moi je suis dans un
département depuis lundi toutes les
vaccinations ont été suspendues par l'
agence régionale de santé faute de deux
doses de vaccin
mais j'ajoute que l'organisation
mondiale de la santé s'inquiète qu'il y
ait seulement aux pays dans le monde qui
monopolisent 90% des vaccins or on est
en face d'une pandémie mondiale qui ne
connaît pas les frontières et donc on
n'éradiquera cette pandémie mondiale
comme dans l'histoire de l'humanité on
aurait éradiquer d'autres maladies qu'en
étant à la
à l'échelle à l'échelle du monné ça ne
peut pas être quelques pays parce qu'ils
ont les capacités financières qu'ils
puissent avoir accès au vaccin il faut
que ce soit bien commun de l'humanité
avec une production massive de façon à
produire à la hauteur de ce qui est
nécessaire pour éradiquer cette
indemnité est ce qu'on est ce qu'on a
les moyens ce que c'est possible de
produire aujourd'hui massivement les
vaccins sont votre territoire et surtout
est-ce qu'on peut le faire immédiatement
moi je pense qu'il faut le faire et en
tout cas
on est dans une course de longue haleine
mais il faut tout de suite se donner des
moyens d'agir efficacement au ronald on
n'agira pas efficacement en étant soumis
à auby semences des industries
pharmaceutiques
il faut que la condition pour pouvoir
avoir un vaccin qui soit à la fois
produit massivement et à la fois
accessible au plus grand nombre y
compris aux pays qui ont beaucoup moins
de 2 de richesse que les pays
occidentaux
il faut que ce vaccin soit sous licence
publique et soit considérée comme un
bien commun comme on l'a c'est
d'ailleurs pour d'autres vaccins afin de
lutter contre l'amant la pandémie on ne
lutteraient pas aujourd'hui efficacement
contre le paludisme pour prendre que
sept que cette maladie sans sens des
vaccins qui sont tombés dans le domaine
public
comment vous expliquer qu'on se retrouve
dans cette situation il ya plusieurs
vagues 500 sur le marché comment vous
expliquer qu'on se retrouve dans cette
situation il n'y a pas que
d'anticipation justement pour permettre
d'accélérer la chaîne de production
je crois que ces sources surtout on est
victime de la dette de la conversion à
l'ultralibéralisme depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années des différents pays
notamment de l'union européenne ou dans
un pays comme la france qui avait une
industrie pharmaceutique très forte qui
étaient issus d'ailleurs du secteur
public sanofi avant d'être sanofi et
d'être surtout d'être une entreprise
privée qui est très mauvais sur le
vaccin mais
et recorman des versements de dividendes
c'était avant une industrie public bon
et donc à force d'avoir baissé la
recherche d'abord versé beaucoup
d'argent public à des entreprises
privées sans contrepartie sans exigences
en matière d'investissements dans la
recherche et le développement et dans
l'est et dans les politiques du
médicament on verse à fonds perdus sans
contrepartie l'ultralibéralisme montre
ses limites c'est à dire le camp quand
tout est donné
au marché on manque de tout et c'est
encore la preuve avec le vaccin
il ya des biens essentiels des biens
vitaux la santé l'éducation qui doivent
ne pas être soumis aux logiques
marchandes
alors on dispose de plusieurs axes
emphaser biotech modern astrazeneca
peut-être bientôt johnson & johnson au
niveau européen emmanuel macron il ne
ferme pas la porte aux vaccins rousse
pique nique des est encore une
déclaration ce matin de du ministre des
affaires étrangères jean yves le drian
qui conditionne bien évidemment les âges
du vaccin bus à l'autorisation de
l'agencé européenne du médicament et à
la haute autorité de la santé en france
il faut y aller vers ce vaccin à bruce
si toutes les conditions sont réunies
mais bien sûr qu'il faut y aller nous le
demandons depuis longtemps c'est
incompréhensible que l'union européenne
dans l'opacité la plus la plus grande
que je rappelle quand même que les
contrats qui ont été passés avec avec
les différentes firmes par l'union
européenne sont absolument pas
transparente puisque même les
parlementaires européens n'ont pas le
droit d'accéder à ces contrats donc nous
demandons depuis le début que le vaccin
russe mais c'est aussi une vraie du
vaccin chinois ou du vaccin acthib fils
est qui cette analyse est regardée être
celui à autorisation bien évidemment
mais on a tous que trop tardé pour des
logiques qui sont encore vélogik
étroitement expertement mercantile donc
je le répète le vaccin russe nous
demandons depuis longtemps il a il a
fait ses preuves les premières analyses
montrent il a un taux de couverture
vaccinale
assez élevé à ses proches d'ailleurs de
ce vide de finder et donc il ya aucune
raison qu on n'accélère pas son
homologation pour accroître nos
capacités de vaccins et étant terminée à
cette info cette manifestation là devant
le siège de father commensaux se déroule
cette manifestation et du monde
quoi s'est déroulé ce déroule bien oui
il ya du moins il ya pas mal de début et
de parlementaires de
deux militants et
bien sûr nous pour le parti communiste
la question de la santé est un sujet qui
nous mobilise beaucoup on été mobilisés
depuis plusieurs années sont à l'hôpital
public et la défense de l'hôpital public
qui a été extrêmement mise à mal et on
s'en est rendu compte avec el kobbi de
19 sur la question du médicament sur la
gratuité sur la défense de la sécurité
sociale parce que si aujourd'hui on
teste et on vaccine gratuitement en
france c'est pas une décision de ce
gouvernement c'est l'héritage d'un d'un
bien commun qui est la sécurité sociale
et on voit bien que les logiques publics
sont efficaces alors que les logiques
qui ne le sont pas
s'agissant de la santé merci beaucoup à
vous c'était un peu d'avoir a répondu en
direct à nos questions depuis la
manifestation devant le siège de files
heures je rappelle donc que vous êtes le
député chien un pcf de seine-saint-denis
siens